and in fact you do need to be especially
at least in something
to be able to make impact to to have to
wait to have a path for yourself but to
make impact at scale you need to be able
to jump between multiple worlds
[Music]
god alone thank you for being on my show
how are you
great great to be here so we had a brief
discussion just now
it was phenomenal a little bit of static
noise so uh with the nature of of
discontinuity and covet where
we're doing this uh god a professor of
operations information and decisions at
upenn director of the m t
program take me to the m t program and
explain to me
first of all who is god alone walk me a
little bit through your journey
and then i'd love to understand why you
chose academia
and you have a very special part in
academia where you have both legs out in
the real world and both legs in academia
your whole work is in the integration of
all of these moving parts so i'd love to
talk about that as well but let's start
with who is god in transition towards
the m t
program yeah absolutely and so first of
all about myself
originally from israel as you probably
can hear from
the accent and from my name was born
there was a
self-taught software developer a from a
fully young age when i was
16 with a fairly big project with intel
and electronics at the time
worked with the several israeli startups
really in the area flight scale
databases
and decide i don't want to be in front
of a computer for the rest of my life
you know little did i know that all of
us are in front of a computer for the
rest of our life
and and was in the military for a few
years uh
a unit is an officer a soldier and
officer again decided that
i don't want to do that move to the us
did my phd at columbia
in decision risk and operations doing
game theory and queuing theory
and really throughout my life was a
combination of
basically everything i said now so work
with big firm
pepsi john deere the airlines but
continuously also
made sure to stay in touch with the more
entrepreneurial world and so work with
israeli firms or in american firms
in very early stages i started my own
firm while i was a it was a kellogg an
educational technology firm that was
acquired later on
um continue to this day to invest in
firms and
be on advisory board of different firms
and always think about the next step
but a few years ago moved to penn a to
be the director of the mnt program that
i'll tell you more about in a minute
but in fact what academia really allows
you is that if you enjoy the ability to
go
deep into an area and then research that
but at the same time
the ability to take that and apply it to
firms and if you have the
ability to move between these two worlds
in a fluent way and i think i i managed
to create a flexibility to do that
it's very hard to compete with that type
of a job it's like being in a
kid in a candy store because you can
continuously pick up what would be your
next project
at the same time you need to have the
patience to see some of these outcomes
right so i mean you were an entrepreneur
until now and you you
with an acquisition behind you you
worked with all these different firms
it seems like the work that you're doing
is still very entrepreneurial also
within
academia because you're looking at our
world you look we're and we'll talk
about the gig economy later
but a lot of the insights that you're
bringing up they're really trying to
understand
how do consumers behave and what type of
solutions work and what types of
types of solutions don't work a lot of
the same thought process that
entrepreneurs do
and and obviously you also have the
privilege of of impacting thousands of
lives through these
through the different classes that you
teach but specifically
through the the wonderful m t program
which i got to know through my good
friend
jay goldman who who is an alumni of that
so tell me a little bit about what this
is and
and why you're helping run it yeah so
the m t program
is a the the oldest coordinated dual
degree program at japan uh
so it's a coordinated agreement meaning
that the kids are getting
a degree from penn and a degree to a
degree from
penn engineering and from work on and
whatever they want in engineering and
whatever they want it works
right but at least when i want to
explain what m t is about i i
have to i mean academia so let me
recommend the book the book is
my favorite book from last year called
range
by david epstein and and he in fact
starts by
comparing tiger woods and roger federer
he said how is that related well
tiger woods most of us are familiar with
the fact that he when he was
really really young two years old
already his father put him on the golf
course and said play
and that was the only focus when he was
a stanford that's the only focus
only focus was goals now many parents in
fact
built their entire educational endeavor
around that method
he's actually talking about roger
federer
roger federer is very different roger
federer while everybody knows of course
that's how good the tennis player was he
said 10 is pretty late
he was a skier he was a soccer player he
was a musician
a squash he was doing many many many
different things and in fact
his mother was a tennis coach and she
did not want to teach him
tennis and so he's talking about
copernicus and van gogh
and many others that actually are
fashioned much more on what
federer did and in fact what m t does
because m t
is really saying you need to be someone
that can build
products so you want people that are
very good engineers people that
understand
design but you also need people that can
motivate people
and build teams can build culture you
can think at the level of an economy
and understand stakeholders and you need
this kind of right
brain left train iq whatever you want to
call that
to really make impact at scale and
that's what like
for him and i can talk about more about
that because it's really beyond just
a program it's an amazing illuminati
and so for example for many of our
students the first
job they got was from an alum the first
investor was an alum
a and and right when they come to campus
you have a really small
group cohort of students that are
continually with you but also you have
an
amazing alumni group you know you look
at the founder of stubhub and snapdeal
in in india
and the guy that runs tmt for goldman
and the guy
randy and t4 ktr and the guy started hur
all of them are alarms and all of them
have amazing access to our students just
willing to come to campus give off do
office hours give skins
advice just an amazing access that i
think does not exist really in any other
equipment program no new and you
mentioned before that this is also one
of the
most difficult programs right out of out
of pen and they
work extremely hard i can testify from
from watching jquery how hard they work
but one thing that i was also very
taking was that when he was so kind to
walk me through
uh through the campus and he took me to
the building where
uh where the m t cohort works out of
pre-cove at times and hopefully post
cover times
and it's really it's it felt like an
open space
of a melting pot of ideas with people
that are
all passionate about about making change
and about innovating right
so some of them i'm guessing are a
little bit more drawn towards certain
areas in engineering some of them a
little more towards finances or business
but but what they're sharing and what
you look for also in the participants is
this yearning passion
for for making change and for being
leaders and and and it sounds to me that
what you're referring to here
the specialist versus the generalist to
make impact at scaling to really change
understand consumer behavior and move
the needle you need to be more of a
generalist
right right exactly and so to some
extent
what you see sometimes people feel
frustrated by being a journalist and in
fact you do need to be especially at
least in something
to be able to make impact to have to
wait to but to make impact at scale you
need to be able
to jump between multiple worlds and it
creates some frustration initially
but in the long term like being a
bilingual right i mean
being bilingual i mean at least
initially you're really not that good in
any one language
and right in the beginning it's very
frustrating but we all know that
bilinguals
are much better in almost everything
they do than people that studied
multiple languages sequentially
this is what we are talking about here
interesting no and obviously at the end
you know it's not to take that they're
stretching themselves thin on either
subject i mean they're excelling at both
the engineering school
and the business school it's not that
they're giving 50 here 50 here
my my guess is that usually they have
pretty good grades and and usually they
come up
close to the top of the class so it
seems a little bit natural
but i'd also love to talk about you know
the workforce and you do
interesting fascinating and remarkable
research with the gig economy which is
an economy that i got introduced to
back in high school when i was running a
startup called any meal and we had to
understand how can we get a lot of
things done
and we didn't have the immediate
resources in my neighborhood for people
to help
and you know without knowing it i had
friends all over the world who work on
who onboarded the the organization in
the company
and they were performing tasks which i
just didn't have the expertise next to
me
so talk to me a little bit about what is
the gig economy and how is it changing a
little bit the mindset of what does it
mean to actually work
yeah it's a great question so first of
all we have to understand
the gay economy on the heels of what
it's being built and so
the reason i almost have to go back to
the introduction of firms firms exist
because of the fact that what we call
transaction cost economics it's very
hard to manage many subcontractors
and that's why i want to be there to
have them within the firm what has
changed multiple things first of all
mobility all of us have a device in our
hands so i can always find someone
second thing is data i always have the
data and the ability
to understand who has the need and who
has the skill and i can try to match
them
right so what it means until you see in
the last few years and you know
the names you hear a lot are of course
uber and lyft and doordash but these are
the
what the firms are interested in are
firms
like upwork and 99 designs and right
it's
our linearity and then you get to firms
that are really
taking whatever mckinsey and bcg and
bain did and say
in fact their slogan was partly married
was
why should you pay for the a partner in
the second vacation
we cannot bring you the consultant but
the guy that does the work we'll bring
you
right and we'll charge you actually only
a fraction of that
and so that's the name rather than
having all of these skills so if
i'm a firm i can get into all of these
if i'm a person i need to design a
website i can find that person
if i'm a person that is designed it's
not from the demand side from the supply
side
you have people that their skills were
very unique too unique
to niche there is no two niche now
why because if there are there is
someone that has the need for your
skills
they will find it they will find them
right they will find somewhere
and so the combination of demand
and supply credit essentially a world of
abundance there is really no shortage of
people anymore in any specific skills
what we need to do however we need to
build the platforms to help and monitor
the matching process
exactly that's what we see now what we
call the economy we talk about usually
about these firms they're doing the
matching between the two and
just to give you an idea we talk about
around two percent of the us
now that making their wow a the majority
of the income from the
the majority the majority of the income
we talk about the fact
that a around 60 million people
had at least one encounter where they
got their income from the
economy um we are talking about the fact
it's going to increase
in the next five years the economy by
the gdp by
around three point five trillion dollars
so we're saying here that
you have over 30 percent of the
workforce just in the us right who is
experienced receiving
compensation for a gig a gig job and and
here
we say gig interchangeably but this
could be that you're in a ride sharing
service and you're not tied to one firm
you're you can go on to multiple firms
right and we see that of course
or it can be that you're on on a firm
like up work or 99 designs and i have to
say that one thing that
truly excites me is that obviously on
our side as
perhaps the the clients we are able to
get things done
quicker more efficiently but on the
other end this
the this two-sided marketplace it
excites me that all of a sudden people
all over the world
not just in the us but people have these
new opportunities that they never had
before
access to internet whether it's a mobile
or a computer now allows anybody in the
philippines to become a book editor
or to become an illustrator for a book
written by
a 24 year old in palo alto right so it's
it's really incredible opportunity
and and and it's mind-boggling how fast
it's growing
right exactly and so that's exactly what
we see we see more and more
labor arbitrage on one side that's kind
of one way to think about it another way
is that people have much more freedom
to actually maintain careers in areas in
the past is very hard to maintain
in location that in the past was very
hard to maintain that's exactly what we
see now
but you do very interesting research on
exactly that question that this
those decisions that a lot of these
people are having to make
one of the things that i'd love to talk
about is
what motivates people right so also so
both in terms of what does it mean to be
a gay worker but then
what are the different factors that
either contribute or lack thereof
towards their motivation to work yeah
that's a great question so first of all
on the
you know from the outside what motivates
them is really the majority of them
actually in fact don't start with that
as a job they start just as a supplement
and then they see it actually offers
them
a lot of flexibility which is really the
main reason most of them are there the
majority is the fact that they
have flexibility they never had before
but now we want to go into the micro and
to me at least the interesting thing
about this economy is that if you think
about
the current economy most of us make
decisions on where to work once a year
once in seven years if you're in
academia once in every maybe
once you get tenure that's your last
decision
people here make decision where how long
and
what task to take minute by minute the
question
we started with was should we start and
develop a whole new labor economy
because you hear a lot of debating the
policy side and and what our friends
should optimize
and so we had to first of all see what
are the main assumptions we need to make
what are the main ideas we need to see
when we look at how these people make
decisions and so we got data from a
ride-sharing firm
on each transaction they had for a whole
year
every offer that was made every job that
was taken everything everything
everything for a whole year
and we look really at three factors we
look at what's the impact of
income the offer basically the wage it's
not really a wage but the equivalent of
wage
right if people are rational
that's the only thing that should matter
and the first thing we saw is that
actually that matters that matters a lot
which really means that most of these
drivers in this case the drivers are
highly rational and saying that because
you hear a lot of
paternalistic approach that says you
need to protect these people and they're
not rational they're captured
and in fact most of them are very
rational wages go up they go more
wages go down they actually drive less
there was a bit of a noise there can you
just go back and re
restate what what did you find are there
are the drivers rational or not and why
why you think that they are so let me
actually first of all outline the three
main factors we looked at we looked at
first of all the impact of
earnings so whether the higher the wage
offered because these drivers get an
offer placed in that firm
and the question was everything else
being equal
if the offers become higher will they
are they more likely to accept the job
and work and the answer was yes
not surprising not surprising surprising
for some people i should say
there are a lot of research from this
from the 90s on on a
taxi drivers where it shows the opposite
that the more you pay them they actually
the less they work
so we shall know but the second thing
that was interesting actually
we look at how much people earned until
now and we saw that people
the more they earned until now the less
likely they're going to continue to work
and the fewer hours they work if they
continue to work so again
the more they earned until now the less
likely they're going to continue to go
do you explain that because they
feel they have a bucket of expectation
in their mind and they're reaching the
top of that expectation yeah
i mean that's the stuff like the main
explanation the main explanation what we
see
is income targeting no one right has a
dream of draw of driving for uber you
want to
drive for uber only to the extent that
allows you to get a certain level
and now you can go and play with your
kids right but here comes probably the
more interesting result the last result
was to look at what's the impact of the
hours they worked until now on the
likelihood to continue to work and here
we saw a very interesting result which
was
the more hours they worked for that
specific firm
the more likely they are to continue and
work for that firm and the longer hours
they continue
and i should say this is within a driver
so it's not a cross driver within the
same driver
take multiple days a day in which you
work longer up to that point
is more likely to continue and going to
work longer
and we that is surprising that's very
surprising that's the first indication
in the literature of that behavior
and we call it inertia and our
explanation for that by the way
is that while these drivers are looking
for flexibility
they also like within that flexibility
they like the ability to maintain
a certain schedule or a certain level of
consistency
now why it's interesting it's just think
primarily because it has significant
implications for policy for example
because if drivers are we know that if
people's
unlike i mean there are many activities
we do in life where we're the only one
impacting ourselves
right here when you put someone on the
road and they want the longer they
driven until now
they're going to drive even longer now
they start posing risks from the clock
and then here what i see is actually
interesting regulation in new york that
really try to monitor
the same drivers across multiple firms
and trying to understand
how do we protect society from people
where they can
actually harm not only themselves which
is you know bad to begin with
but actually harm society evolved and of
course there's a conflict of interest
because a lot of these firms they have
they're they have an incentive to keep
as many drivers on the road at any given
moment
because that gives me a better
experience because i have a match within
a minute right i'm curious do you think
that is
a similar behavior exhibited by gig
workers
in other industries or is it or or is
that primarily thing for
for mobility that's a great question
that's what we're trying to understand
now
uh but i'll say one thing however what
you said i don't think the firm always
would like to keep drivers driving
i think the friends in fact when i speak
with firms with people in these firms
and that's now across the board
they would like people to be on the road
when there is work
and they prefer that they be home when
there is no work
they believe that they actually pay
exactly they actually believe they pay
in goodwill if these drivers are going
around looking for jobs and there is no
job
so predicting behavior is actually
really really key for them
this is fascinating what what other
things because the gig workers is
something that's been
your recent endeavor right but but
you've done more research across the
years so what are some what are some
other really interesting questions that
you've been asking yourself throughout
this research that are relevant to the
world of entrepreneurship yeah so you
know one area that i've been dealing
with quite a bit in the last few years
is how people process information
and and let me explain what i mean by
that we are in an era
where more than any time in history
we're more information
in our hands and in fact we see
people potentially know less
about the world than we know in the past
and so that's where we started we
started we said in a world where people
have more information
but this information is coming in a very
high speed in a very very
small chunks when i talk about that i'm
really talking about this the fact that
information has the size of a screen and
within the screen
we have very little time to decide what
we read and we move on and now there is
a new
flow of information so we look at that
situation and we say in a world like
that
where also the information sources are
more and more unknown right i mean think
about like the world that i was born
i was born to we had two newspapers
you know in the u.s was the nerd times
and the washington post and the
washington
it was a journal maybe in israel were
different a you had
one or two tv channels maybe three now
we don't talk about the nerd times
anymore we talked about is it maggie
hammerman
or is it someone else i mean each and
every source now is a different source
if you look at
many of the people actually brought
coven into attention were not even from
the main
journals many of them were actually side
players
right so when you the question we look
at is a situation where you look at the
data
and and one of the things we show in
fact is that because of the fact that we
have proliferation of sources that
are in themselves are not very credible
when they say not credible
some of them are credible i'm not
talking about fake news by the way i'm
talking about really the fact that we
are trying to assess
the level of information at the same
time that we're trying to figure out
what is really the truth if we do that
what we get we get to see it it's
actually a highly polarized world and
then why we get a highly polarized world
because when i have valid information
i'm going to evaluate from wherever i
am i want to evaluate given the
information i have and if the
information is already polarized it
would become even more and more
organized
the reason it's interesting for me is
that we live in a world of platforms and
what we can think about is how do we
regulate
many of them but what we are trying to
show in fact is that
regulation unless you really understand
why
we see what we see we might actually
regulate
the wrong side of innovation and that's
what i'm worried about i'm worried about
then not to think about the
counterfactual when trent tend to not
think about the implications of
regulation
um without truly understanding how
people make a decision whether it's
drivers whether it is about information
news sources whatever it is about and so
that's an overarching sort of like
a theme of what i'm trying to do and as
you can see many of that is really
talking about
things that have changed the last few
years so a lot of it is impacted by
current changes in technology
and in the way we consume information
and just
in just a minute what why why professor
why teach
why why stand in front of a of
classrooms uh sometimes dozens sometimes
hundreds of students
and and talk about these things that
that you're researching
yeah so that's a great question and in
fact i the faculty at the technion
the avi medal bomb that said whenever
you do anything you have to think about
what is your scope of impact
when you do consulting it's five minutes
from now when
you teach executive mba students it's a
year from now
when you teach undergrad mba is five
years long with each undergrad it's 25
years from now
many of them are it's too early for them
to impact it now but
impact nba five years from now but
undergraduate 25 years from now yeah and
then research 75 years from now
right i mean you want to teach people
how to think
not only a lot of things you want to
teach them
the way and in fact that's that impact
is very very hard to have
in any other way and so i i enjoy being
in the classroom love being in the
classroom uh
many of my students i'm still in touch
with them in fact almost every week i
speak with two three students former
students wow
so very hard to replicate this type of
experience
unbelievable god hey before we leave i
want to thank you again for being so
generous with your time
and this is just wonderful and
insightful and i and i love watching the
different
lectures that you have youtube and i
urge anybody who's remotely interested
in any of these questions that you're
asking yourself which i'm sure
every young entrepreneur is because the
the labor force and decision making
and and and operations and processing
information is
that's that's what 2020 is about and of
course moving forward
and but before we leave i have to ask
you for three words that you would use
to describe yourself
yeah so i'll say first of all
integrative i i believe in integrative
thinking i i try to integrate many
things
rigorous i try to go as deep as i can to
every topic i take
and very direct my students know that
i'm very direct in everything i say
both to be negative michael great to be
here
i love it god thank you very very much
and this is just wonderful take care
you